[Music]
hello
is that james
yeah he's me there is a
problem happening right now on youtube
investment scams they comment on a lot
of youtube investment videos join up on
these videos
scams are happening right now it's a
real problem that needs to be addressed
before anyone else falls victim to
what's going on
here's how it usually goes you'll click
on a video of mine
scroll through the comments only to find
a user by the name of james janney or at
least some variation of my name
responding to people with a whatsapp
number and encouraging the victim to
message that number
these comments have absolutely swarmed
my videos
and sometimes they don't just
impersonate me you might also see
a generic comment with a lot of upvotes
and replies which
look like they're coming from real
people with real profiles usually
they're talking about
investing or cryptocurrencies but
they'll always reference
a guru that helped them make a lot of
money followed by that guru's number to
contact
i've tried deleting and reporting the
accounts but i could spend an entire day
deleting comments only to wake up the
next morning to countless more
all the while wishing that there was
something i could do to stop them
and then i had an idea i wanted to meet
my impersonators and scammers
face to face
the predators were to become the prey
[Music]
i began by going over to my own channel
clicking on my most recent video
and diving into the comment section
below within seconds i found
three different scammers impersonating
me and responding to other comments
the first imposter went by the name of
james jan
who replied to a comment advising
someone to get into cryptocurrency with
the aid of my supposed trusted trader
roland lurch shortly followed with a
whatsapp number to contact
the second imposter responded to a
comment thanking a viewer for their
feedback
and instructed them to message a number
on whatsapp that differed from the first
although for all i knew both imposters
could have been part of the same
operation
but there was one in particular who
caught my eye the third imposter went by
the name of
pined by james jane in a strange attempt
to make it seem as if the comment was
pinned by me
this impostor had been replying to
multiple comments on my videos for days
and i decided they were going to be my
target
from now on we'll call this scammer fake
james
equipped with a new number and a fake
whatsapp profile i was ready to discover
exactly what happened when someone tried
to contact these scammers
it was time to meet my imposters beyond
the comment section
i added their number into my phone and
immediately i was greeted with a generic
profile picture looks like we've got the
right number now
it was time for our first message
they've taken the bait it wasn't long
before
fake james tells me that they can help
me earn amazing guaranteed profits
how through their bitcoin and
cryptocurrency mining machines
of course they then send me a block of
text telling me that if i invest
five hundred dollars it'll give me 5 500
if i invest 1 000 it'll give me eleven
thousand dollars
and if i invest two thousand dollars
it'll give me twenty two thousand
dollars
fake james was offering me a money
printing machine
but before handing over any money i push
to get fake james who remember is
pretending to be me
on a voice call and after some
convincing they agree
so far it all sounds too good to be true
and more than a little shady
so why would anyone fall for this i've
had people email
and tweet at me telling me that they've
contacted these scammers thinking that
they were actually me or someone related
to me i was quick
to judge wondering why people could be
so gullible but then it dawned on me
these scammers are doing something very
clever
they're hacking into basic human nature
[Music]
hello is that james yeah i'm a huge fan
of your work i appreciate you taking
the time to go on the cool with me
tell me about the investment man i want
to i want to get rich let's get rich
[Music]
together
[Music]
wow so how does it work then do i send
it over to you
oh of course yeah yeah of course
[Music]
i didn't give my imposter the money but
i did send them a photo of me
letting them know that we share the
exact same name my fun didn't stop there
though
i grew more curious and began contacting
other scammers in the comments
it became somewhat of an addiction and
the more i continued the more
bizarre things became one comment thread
on my video
had tons of real comments recommending
an individual by the name of greg
t martin greg was supposedly a trader
offering to invest
on my behalf and after i made contact he
sent me a link to an actual website
which appeared to be his own trading
platform
in order to get started i would need to
deposit funds on it of course
those funds would have to be sent to a
bitcoin wallet completely
untraceable greg even sent me a link to
his facebook and instagram profile
encouraging me to look at them
and that's when things took an
interesting turn greg's profile featured
the same individual
in multiple pictures his facebook
boasted devoted followers tagging him in
their posts
thanking him for the success and profits
they've now seen because of him
greg's instagram contained videos of him
actually talking
alright guys so i'm super super excited
i'm super inspired
there was just one problem the greg
talking in the video had an american
accent and the greg that was messaging
me
didn't you know when it comes to
investment greg was likely using
someone else's images on their social
media profiles as bait
motivated by all i had discovered so far
i continued my hunt
contacting more scammers in the comments
my name is james chatty
well but a slow realization was creeping
in
there were an infinite amount of
scammers either part of the same
operation or multiple operations
seeing what they were up to while using
my own name was one thing but i had
no real way of stopping them and so i
retreated to twitter and sent a tweet
directly at youtube
asking how are they dealing with the
scammers in the comments
no response and then a glimmer of hope i
get a message from my buddy richard who
runs the plain bagel youtube channel who
i know has been struggling with these
scammers as well
richard refers me onto a man named andre
andre i find out has created a software
called social clean that connects with
your youtube channel
this software had its own algorithm for
detecting scammer comments and getting
rid of as many
of them as possible and so with no other
options left
i decided to give andre's creation a go
and for the most part
it works now a quick disclaimer i'm not
sponsored by andre or socialclean and
from what i've heard there are
alternative options out there it also
costs money although there is a free
version of it available to use
now not all scammer comments had been
removed by andre's algorithm
but the scammers were no longer able to
post whatsapp numbers for people to
contact
so it seemed like a good option to keep
my viewers safe we had managed to solve
the problem
or so i thought these scammers don't
just inhabit the space of youtube
they're on tick tock now
as well strange comments flooding
financial related tick tocks all doing a
similar thing
and then i began receiving messages from
others
telling me that they've been contacted
by me on instagram
only it wasn't me an imposter who had
taken a username similar to my own using
my own profile picture and having
purchased
fake followers now they were messaging
my followers in an attempt to swindle
them out of their money
this wasn't about scammers in the
youtube comment section anymore this was
something
much larger than parasitical
i don't remember who told me this or
whether it's just common marketing
advice
but if you see someone doing something
over and over again
even if you think it's horrible
advertising it means
it's working i often thought when
looking at these comments
surely nobody would fall for this right
but of course
people are falling for it because
fundamentally
these scammers are exploiting something
that exists within
all of us something that is embedded in
our code as humans
you know how some sitcoms have a canned
laughter track that plays when someone
makes a joke
yes from what i can tell
most people don't like laughter tracks
they sound forced it feels patronizing
it interrupts the flow of the scene
but they're there because they work it's
been documented that candle off the
tracks actually
help make bad jokes funnier hearing
others laugh
even though we know it's fake encourages
us to find things funny as well it acts
as social proof
typically when unsure of how to act in a
social situation
we've not encountered before we take
cues from people around us
especially when it's someone we like or
we trust
it's why before purchasing a product we
haven't purchased before we look at the
reviews first
it's why brands choose to have
influencers promote their products
because we're more likely to buy based
on the recommendation of someone we
trust
over a regular advert this is the secret
that allows these scammers and imposters
to continue when impersonating me
they are leveraging any trust that
people might have for me and using it
against them
when you see those generic comments with
a bunch of upvotes your brain is tricked
into thinking that
many of these people are in support of
this person then as you read the replies
you're further led to believe that these
are real people having a real
conversation
and when multiple accounts are
recommending a particular broker
or financial advisor you're given even
more social proof
what makes things worse is that some of
these scammers target
financial related content because
they're aware that most people don't
know how to invest their money in stocks
or cryptocurrencies
it's an unfamiliar environment so when
james janney responds to your comment
telling you to send him a message on
whatsapp where he proceeds to show you
how much money you can make with him
you're more inclined to believe one of
the scammers i contacted who went by the
name of laura
even sent me over a few videos that were
supposed to be testimonials from her
clients
i'm very grateful thank you i appreciate
it a lot you helped me out right now all
y'all gotta do is do what she's saying
go with the steps
invest on it and you will see your money
now suppose you didn't use youtube a lot
or you'd never seen these scammer
comments before and perhaps you were in
a desperate situation financially
these testimonials would be incredibly
convincing
of course this scam is built up from
fabricated information that is used to
give the
impression of social proof these
testimonials are likely taken from
other corners of the internet and cut
out of context the james janney
responding to comments or sending
messages to my followers on instagram
isn't the real me the upvotes on the
generic comments are from bots and the
responses come from other fake accounts
and that was the realization that i had
to come to terms with
that i can't eradicate these scammers
and whilst andre software had helped
clear out many scammer comments in my
own videos
it can't prevent scammers in the
comments of other channels even if
youtube were to somehow find a way of
detecting and getting rid of these
scammers they would show up in other
ways and other platforms as we've
already seen them do
in order to prevent us from being the
victim we have to be able to distinguish
when social proof is legitimate or being
used in a misleading
and fabricated way now i made this video
because i was tired of seeing my viewers
be
bombarded by my impostors thinking that
this could actually be me
trying to rope them in and con them but
ultimately the only
real way for us to stop these scammers
is to understand why we fall for them
in the first place
[Music]
some people are falling for these scams
measures could be put in place so that
this doesn't happen to anybody else
it's not a scam i guarantee you it's not
the school
[Music]
hello my friends and thank you for
watching to the end of the video
before you click off i do want to say if
you catch any of the scammers in the
comments there should be fewer of them
but if you do
give them a little slap on the wrist and
make sure people know that this is a
scam etc etc but look if you enjoyed the
video do give it a like do subscribe to
the channel and promise
to bless your feed with good content i
really appreciate all of you i
maybe sometimes don't get to say this as
much with the amount of uploads i do on
the channel
um but i really do appreciate all of you
who watch the content and enjoy it if
you do want to see some extra stuff
behind the scenes content q and a's with
me
video editing tutorials all of that
stuff i have a patreon
go and subscribe it's awesome place over
there um if you really really do want to
support the channel
that is the place to go otherwise i wish
you all the best rest of the day my
friends
as always hand to head many salute
is yet to come
too many times has come to pass